música psicología e inversiones como
estas tres disciplinas me transformaron
la vida
de pequeño tuve la fortuna de crecer en
una casa en una familia con bastante
solidez económica bastante holgada pero
fue en mi adolescencia cuando me
enfrenté a lo que en su momento
experimenté como grandes tragedias pasé
por dos embargos con mi familia
la primera vez recuerdo como extraño se
entraron a mi casa tomaban nuestras
cosas y las sacaban a la calle a la
vista de todo el mundo
ese fue mi primer encuentro con la
inestabilidad con los cambios súbitos
años más tarde regresaba de la escuela y
acostumbraba a tocar la batería porque
me encantaba era mi gran pasión en ese
entonces pero en el segundo embargo
cuando vi nuevamente personas sacando
cosas de nuestra casa
mi mamá se acercó y me dijo
hijo desarma tu batería porque se la van
a llevar
fue en ese preciso momento que me hice
una promesa jamás me iba a permitir
vivir una inestabilidad un cambio tan
radical como es en mi vida en su lugar
me iba a asegurar de tener una vida
estable próspera y segura
pero qué creen
un momento clave llegó en mi elección
profesional
de pequeño cometí el error de decir que
quería ser abogado ya saben mi familia
se quedó con esa idea pero cuando cambie
de opinión porque descubrí que mi
vocación real era la psicología me
enfrenté a cuestionamientos por parte de
mi familia y personas cercanas me decían
psicólogo de que vas a vivir si es de
las peores profesiones pagadas del país
esas estadísticas eran reales
cómo vas a mantener una familia y más si
eres hombre en un país muy machista
lo peor de todo esto es que estas
preguntas se conectaban con mis temores
y esa promesa que yo me había hecho
pero un día leí una frase que resonó más
fuerte que ese discurso que me decía
rechaza tu pasión y mejor busca lo
seguro
esa frase
lo que eres
esta frase del mismísimo aristóteles
silencio esos miedos esas voces que me
decían escucha otras voces sino la tuya
pero escuche la mía gracias a él
decidí ser psicólogo tuve muchos éxitos
sí pero lo más paradójico es que aún así
yo seguía teniendo temor al cambio a la
inestabilidad y a la incertidumbre
no solamente eso sino que a través de mi
profesión todos los problemas que me
planteaban tenían como denominador común
eso habían dejado de ser quiénes eran
algunos por miedo al fracaso otros por
cubrir expectativas de las personas por
las críticas y otras porque pusieron el
dinero como el único fin el resultado
era el mismo una insatisfacción
terrible
pues un día
acompañado de mi pasión por la música y
la psicología analice estas gráficas
esta que ven aquí es la gráfica del
sonido de una batería
esta otra es la actividad de los
neurotransmisores que están totalmente
relacionados con nuestras diferentes
emociones y trasladándolo al mundo de
las finanzas me di cuenta que ambas se
comportaban igual que ésta
que el gráfico de las acciones de una
empresa en la bolsa de valores me di
cuenta que el mundo bursátil era
totalmente equiparable al de la música y
de la psicología y no sólo eso sino que
cuando decidí formarme meterme a fondo
de esto me di cuenta que detrás de estas
gráficas que ustedes ven lo único que
hay son personas apretando botones de
comprar y vender cuando sienten miedo
ante la pérdida cuando sienten avaricia
para ganar o cuando sienten ansiedad
porque no saben qué va a pasar la
incertidumbre como decía alexander
hélder esto no es otra cosa que
psicología de las masas aplicadas a un
monitor
no por nada los inversionistas más
exitosos sí o sí han trabajado en su
mentalidad porque la psicología del
inversionista es una pieza fundamental
para poder ser rentable en los mercados
así descubrí mi tercer pasión las
inversiones
y de estas tres disciplinas las
enseñanzas que tuve puede encontrar
cuatro principios que transformaron mi
vida pero no sólo eso finalmente me
dieron la respuesta a este miedo a la
incertidumbre del cambio cómo manejarlas
primero
estar abajo es parte del proceso
intenté imaginar una canción que siempre
estuviera en el clímax ese momento donde
todos brincamos o cantamos el coro y
siempre sostenidamente simplemente no
hacía sentido hasta en los géneros
musicales más intensos
es posible encontrar momentos de
silencio más tranquilos cierto pues
igual que en las canciones en la vida
era totalmente insostenible esperar una
vida lineal sin caída sin fluctuaciones
y por alguna razón yo me había comprado
esa idea
de que para tener esta vida segura uno
tiene que estar siempre en el máximo
nivel máximo de energía de pasión de
optimismo y pasará lo que pasará
y cuando me tocaba perder cuando las
cosas no salían como yo quería cuando no
eran perfectas yo simplemente no sabía
qué hacer
peor tantito me convertí en mi peor juez
porque no había nadie que se juzgará
peor o que me juzgará peor que yo mismo
con no me salían las cosas bien
y las inversiones curiosamente me lo
recalcaron mientras no aceptaba yo
perder perdía más de lo que debía y casi
que me di cuenta pero cuando empecé
asumir mis pérdidas a reconocerlas a
tiempo empecé a ser rentable en la bolsa
así deje de luchar con los cambios
abrace las pérdidas en mi vida
estar abajo es simple y sencillamente
parte del cuerpo el segundo principio lo
descubrí después que se puede ganar en
las caídas las inversiones me enseñaron
está en primer lugar literalmente en las
acciones cuando caen uno puede ganar
dinero si es que uno decide ponerse del
lado correcto del mercado y toma la
decisión de hacerlo y luego relacione el
concepto más básico de la música es el
arte de combinar los sonidos y los
silencios con armonía y ritmo
es decir que nuestras caídas en nuestras
crisis en nuestros silencios no
solamente tenemos grandes desafíos sino
son grandes oportunidades donde tal vez
obtengamos alguna ganancia
o no esa y acaso donde nos reencontramos
con nosotros donde somos más sensibles a
las cosas que suceden donde nos
reconstruimos donde encontramos
habilidades y talentos que ni siquiera
sabíamos que éramos posibles de tener
porque no nos quedaba otra opción en ese
momento
es ahí donde algunos de nosotros en
nuestras caídas encontramos un propósito
así me di cuenta que las personas que
combinan sus silencios con armonía y
gran maestría nos regalan las más
grandes sinfonías de vida esto me hizo
ser consciente del tercer principio
al analizar para variar estas tres
disciplinas me di cuenta que si había
movimientos hacia arriba o hacia abajo
pero había una tercera dirección que no
había sido tan consciente
el movimiento lateral
cuando una acción en el mercado cae
siempre es necesario el movimiento
lateral para volver a subir y
recuperarse de ese nivel que cayó en
nuestras crisis en nuestras caídas la
paciencia como la lateralidad es
necesaria para retomar el camino para
salir de alguna mala racha
pensé cuántas veces no nos encontramos
en movimientos laterales en nuestras
vidas y por no saber esperar lo
suficiente terminamos relaciones
abandonamos proyectos o en la bolsa las
personas pierden porque no saben esperar
porque tan de moda está el saber soltar
y aprender a soltar pero ya pocos
aprenden a sostener entender este
principio me hizo darme cuenta que a
veces si es esperar y hay que poner las
probabilidades a nuestro lado nada más
esto de las probabilidades a nuestro
favor me hizo llegar al cuarto y último
principio
lo que parece distante e inconexo se
puede unir esto que ven aquí es la
figura estándar del patrón de
movimientos de estas tres disciplinas
tienen altos bajos y lateralidad es
en diferentes colores les pongo un
simbolismo de diferente talento
intereses pasión que puedas tener se
unen
pero no se unen por sí solas las crisis
que vivimos
las personas que nos encontramos en el
camino de vida para bien o para mal y a
veces el tiempo estos elementos que ven
de color amarillo
un en líneas lo queramos o no por alguna
razón
pero también hay otras cuestiones que no
son eventos que no controlamos como esto
sino que si está en nuestras manos y son
actos que podemos hacer para unir como
el ser quienes somos independientemente
de nuestros miedos de las críticas de
los demás enfrentarlos y vencerlos unas
líneas
la educación por supuesto no se trata
nada más quiero hacer esto es tomo el
compromiso y me formó para poder unir lo
que yo quiero unir y 30 pero muy
importante para unir con solidez
cualquier día cualquiera de nuestras
líneas siempre va a ser necesario el
trabajo el esfuerzo y la práctica
así con nuestros diferentes elementos
vamos encontrando y trazando esto
una gráfica única de nuestras vidas en
donde unimos talentos pasiones donde nos
enfrentamos a circunstancias que no
controlamos y actos que también
decidimos hacer y así se va graficando
salimos de nuestras caídas bajamos de
nuestras subidas
la música la psicología y las
inversiones me enseñaron que además de
ser pasiones podrían resultar ser
respuestas de vida justamente porque me
permite unirlas la música la psicología
y las inversiones me enseñaron que la
respuesta no estaba en el instrumento
musical sino en el músico que no estaba
en las cosas buenas o malas que no
suceden sino en la persona en sí misma y
que para ser éxito exitoso en las
finanzas no se requiere el capital
necesariamente si no se trata del
inversionista te invito a que seas
consciente de ti mismo
identifica tus talentos identifica tus
pasiones relaciona las analiza las saca
el mayor provecho que puedas de cada una
de ellas
pero no lo hagas a la ligera
comprométete con este arduo porque es
arduo pero muy apasionante y liberador
proceso de ser quién eres
permite serlo a los demás también
porque así como la innovación de la que
hablamos en las organizaciones hoy en
día está tan de moda mejor enfócate
también en la innovación más importante
y trascendente de todas
la innovación personal
el arte de reinventarse
se lo que eres
y recuerda que la mejor forma de
enfrentar tus miedos y de encontrar
respuestas no se logra renunciando a tus
elementos sino uniendo los cucharas
[Aplausos]